et elle nous a rejoint c'est amal
bentounès y mènent tous ni d'ailleurs
c'est bien ce que je pensais tounsi
tunisien voilà c'est ça non je sais que
vous étiez au théâtre vous arriver juste
du théâtre merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
donc on le rappelle le 21 avril 2012 un
policier tue votre frère d'une balle
dans le dos vous avez créé ensuite
l'association urgence notre police
assassines c'est très violent déjà comme
non surtout voilà pour nos policiers je
pense que là qui sont là ce soir quand
vous entendez urgence notre police
assassines pourquoi avoir choisi ce nom
d'association alors un moment donné il
fallait il fallait interpellé en fait on
avait l'impression d'être inaudible pas
forcément mon affaire la sphère où mon
frère a été tué mais je me suis rendu
compte que d'autres familles vivaient le
même drame que moi et on avait cette
difficulté là à pouvoir être entendue
donc je me suis dit c'est une façon
comme une autre d'interpeller est la
preuve
ça a marché puisque à l'époque manuel
valls ministre de l'intérieur avait
porté plainte pour diffamation envers
une autorité publique alors vous pouvez
nous raconter l'histoire de votre frère
amine donc qui est qui a été tué d'une
balle dans le dos en avril 2012 oui
alors là j'ai entendu les extraits donc
je voudrais juste relevé de dire que
c'est la version policière qui avait été
dans un premier temps relayé alors
qu'elle était la version policière rôle
alors la version policière c'est que mon
frère était surarmés et que le policier
était en état de légitime défense
jusque là on va dire rien
d'extraordinaire c'est un bras car
apparemment d'après sont peu diserts
c'est un braqueur est que ce policier
s'est tout simplement défendu alors
effectivement amine c'était le client
parfait
amin on lui a pas fait de cadeau ça a
été le premier jeune prisonnier de
france à l'âge de 13 ans effectivement
que c'était le client parfait pour cette
affaire et à ce moment là je me suis dit
c'est pas possible c'est pas possible
qu'il ait joué comme ça et qui perd et
je me suis je
dis ça au départ parce que bon ok je
suis proche de lui
mais en même temps je me suis dit merde
il a joué il a perdu et à un moment
donné je me suis dit non quand même on
va aller peut-être chercher un peu plus
loin on va demander une autopsie
alors je vais appeler mon avocat je vais
lui demander de me constituer partie
civile
je vais mener des actions pendant trois
mois des manifestations sur place en
criant en demandant aux gens de dire
s'ils ont vu quelque chose pour la
vérité pour la justice effectivement
cette mobilisation a payé puisque de un
témoin de celui qui s'était pris une
balle sur le bas de caisse de sa voiture
on est passé à sept témoins et sept
témoins qui disent exactement la même
chose qui dise quoi qu'ils disent amine
courait il était de dos et à aucun
moment il a porté atteinte à la vie de
ce policier et concernant les arbres
soit dix ans dont il était en possession
alors fuir figurez vous on retrouve
effectivement une arme puisque le procès
a eu lieu le policier a été condamné
on retrouve une âme donc sur cette arme
étrangement il ya quatre adn différents
quatre adn différentes qui ne correspond
pas à celle de mon frère
d'accord voilà donc mon frère n'avait
pas de grands à ce moment là et les
témoins disent contredisent la version
policière et jusqu'à à ce que un
policier un collègue de damien
saboundjian on pollueurs trier de mon
frère à 1026 and ses collègues au
premier procès s'effondre à la barre et
avoue son mensonge on a vu lors à la wii
il avoue un mensonge il a été condamné
les policiers de plus il a été condamné
en deuxième instance
effectivement puisque à ce moment là
c'est le procureur de bobigny qui a fait
appel et heureusement qu'il a fait appel
puisque sinon on n'aurait pas eu la
possibilité d'obtenir justice
alors pour vous parce que là c'est ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on dit depuis le début
on il faut pas mettre tous les policiers
dans le même panier faut pas mettre tous
les gens de banlieue dans le même panier
et c'est bien c'est bien normal vous est
ce que pour vous tous les policiers sont
des assassins de la police roulant vous
leur en voulais tellement que
non pas du tout je leur en veux pas je
n'en veux à personne je je suis juste
lac je constate moi effectivement
c'était pas mon métier j'étais pas
militante j'étais commercial je gagnais
très bien ma vie et malheureusement je
me retrouve à militer et parce
qu'aujourd'hui ça me porte
ça me porte patio des affaires comme
théo des affaires comme celle d'amadou
coup mais qui a été tuée par asphyxie
comme celle de wissam et liam ni comme
celle de hamid ait un gars qui a été tué
de 26 balles celle de abdoulaye camara
celle de angelo garant dernièrement vous
avez romain 26 ans tué par un policier
alors que ce policier a réquisitionné
moto et s'est permis d'aller course et
ce jeune homme qui n'avait juste juste
un défaut à défaut de permis et qui a
pris la fuite
donc voilà c'est ça qui est scandaleux
c'est qu'à un moment donné moi je dis
pas que tous les policiers sont des
assassins en puissance c'est pas là mais
ce que je dis c'est qu'à un moment donné
face à l'inrs et à l'inacceptable
il faut reconnaître la vérité quand même
un moment donné quand on a ses collègues
qui commettent des actes de torture et
de barbarie
là quand je vois tes os qui est là avec
nous qu'ils attaquent
il est la digne et face à vous et qu'on
arrive à lui dire que il est presque
coupable de ce qui lui est arrivé c'est
quand scandaleux c'est quand même
scandaleux par nous a dû trouver c'est
maintenant défendre maintenant il faut
arrêter d'averses et les rôles dans les
séries si on est capable de se défendre
et ça se passe bien c'est pas à moi
d'argumenter pour la ferté haut
maintenant concernant votre frère est ce
qu'on peut reconstitue alizés les choses
je sais pas pourquoi ils pourraient
enfin je suis désolé rejeu alors à ce
que je suis ce que je sais votre farce
était un fugitif ça va chercher peu à
part valls la finalité soulignant qu'on
souhaiterait pas mal on raccourci très
rapporte à mal on va on va rapper donc
pas de consensus
le policier interpellé alors mon frère
effectivement il est en cavale il avait
écopé de plusieurs années de prison lors
d'une permission il
jamais retourné en prison pendant deux
ans il est en cavale donc c'est un
fugitif
oui c'est un fugitif on peut appeler ça
capote ans est mort mais pourtant
poursuivi par des policiers avec méfier
de recherche les petits qui peut être
potentiellement armé de la porte à aucun
moment vous vie s'est passé c'est que
c'est dans le dos oui mais c'est noël
dans le doubs
si vous êtes forcément donné qu'il a pas
mal de balles dans le dos forcément
c'est c'est monsieur yan automatique
léger pas de la balle pendant deux ans
ça c'est pas pour l'abbé armand c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il se bat dans d'autres
forcément la police est coupable pas
forcément
je compte d'une voiture et je fonce sur
la foule le policier de dos et peut
tirer il la balle sera trop dans le dos
mais pour autant il faut laisser ça va
beaucoup nom madoff coupable oui elle a
arrêté de 32 c à vous il ya eu des
chutes vous faire 50 noms de personnes
qui sont mortes effectivement par balles
mais ces personnes s'y attendait un peu
de respect pour les femmes je reste je
respect pour les familles et vous
profitez c'est quand même d'être un peu
importe quoi voilà maintenant je vais je
suis dit je vous sers manque de révision
de procès minute tous les autres a
raconté pour m'habituer à ce fléau vous
disais rapport le dernier cas vous avez
raconté un policier s'est permis de
prendre son temps et poursuivre
quelqu'un non c'est pas ça
la personne est en fuite un délit de
fuite le policier sera pour les moyens
qu'ils utilisent pour poursuivre la
personne il poursuit une personne à
réquisition est possible donc il
poursuit le conducteur et tous les
témoins sur place disent qu'au moment où
la personne se marche arrière et de
percuter un pauvre ce côté risque a
demandé à personne rien personne
derrière le policier a fait feu tous les
témoins sont unanimes et vous me dites
que ce policier là les coupables de
violences policières vous me dites la
police assassines ne sais pas si c'est
fait du droit de votre vie ou pas mais
un assassinat année de droit alors
prémédité et dans tous les cas que vous
me citer jamais eu préméditation
j'aimerais association n'a même pas lieu
d'exister le nom et que totalement faux
alors on va on va on va voir là c'est la
rivière
c'est à faire venir mais ce que je veux
dire à guillaume et un maillet qui sont
avec nous c'est que ça mais quand tu es
ya un procès qui a statué quand il ya
des éléments qui ont démontré dans un
tribunal que quelqu'un a tiré dans le
dos de quelqu'un qui n'est pas donc en
légitime défense et autres je pense que
vous ne défendez pas la corpo et surtout
ici policière à boulange en tentant de
recontextualiser je ne sais quoi
un moment donné l'une défendable il faut
pas essayer de le défendre
je pense que si la justice est passée et
je pense que nous verrons est ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure il y a dans
le compost aux policiers des brebis
galeuses
je ne dis pas que c'en était une je dis
peut-être il a perdu les pédales je dis
peut-être qu'il a il il a manqué à son
devoir de fonction de police qui n'a pas
appliqué la déontologie et les règles et
les principes qu'on ait dicté aux
fournisseurs pour les uns ce cas de
figure mais là vous ne pouvez pas
essayer de défense quelqu'un qui a été
condamné et vous vous demandez rière je
n'ai pas sûr mais le truc ça n'a pas
duré le procès en fait ça n'a pas
d'accord moi je suis la première fois le
juge a déclaré que des policiers ont
fait appel des monnaies et regret qu'on
écoute eric revel je suis quand même
très mal à l'aise je vais vous dire je
suis quand même très mal à l'aise parce
que j'entends karim qui donnent de la
voix qui emploie des mots parfois on se
demande si les avocats ou homme
politique et je suis très mal à l'aise
parce que là j'ai l'impression que les
deux et qu'on fait on peut être les deux
victoires et de nicolas sarkozy mais que
là on fait un procès qui est le procès
de la police mal à moi je m'incline
devant la mémoire de votre frère et
c'est un drame affreux mais je vais non
mais vous devrez vous à l'idée de
changer de la fra nous les aimons la
fessée le fener connais pas atterri
crevaison marc pas parce que ça me
rendrait service à personne et pas la
république française que la police soit
mise en accusation comme on le fait
depuis le début on n'est même pas en
accusation
quelque chose comme on abat
et je m'intéresse c'est encore une fois
je m'incline devant la mémoire de votre
frère parce que je ne j'ai entendu
parler évidemment de ce drame mais je ne
connais pas le détail vous avez dit il
s'est retrouvé en prison à 13 ans oui
mais c'est un drame c'est un drame pour
la socialite madame madame comment
peut-on se retrouver en prison at région
qu'est ce que l'on fait
qu'est ce que l'on fait pour se
retrouver en prison à 13 ans parce que
c'est pour un foot pour un feu de
poubelle on se retrouve aux prises
résout à faire 6 mois de prison ferme à
fleury mérogis votre pour un full popov
a fait tous ces brèches et le mali c'est
pas les élections a dit qu de 13 ans qui
a été jugée avait lancé sur le véhicule
de police dans lequel j'étais un
cocktail molotov il avait 13 ans il n'a
rien d'accord donc à l'heure actuelle
personnellement j'ai jamais été près
d'une école
d'accord cette école il y avait personne
mon c'était un mercredi ils ont ils ont
supposé que c'était un incendie criminel
corps donc c'est ce qui a fait que amis
accor s'est retrouvé à l'âge de 13 ans
en prison
donc il a écopé de six mois et j'ai eu
beau supplier les juges leur dire non ne
mettez pas mon frère en prison entre les
braqueurs les violeurs et tout ce qui
s'ensuit
non ah bon on n'a pas écouté mon frère
voilà on l'a on l'a tué une fois à 13
ans et on l'a tué à 29 ans ramous en
fait de pour moi depuis tout à l'heure
on est en train de me tromper de débat
c'est à dire que yann balland de tennis
et tout le monde sait maintenant mais
c'est vous n'en mais c'est moi bien sûr
que toutes les victimes de n'importe
quel drame qu'ils soient policiers qui
soit quelqu'un de lambda c'est très
grave
mais là on est en train de parler pour
rien dire c'est à dire qu'on trouve pas
la solution on n'essaye pas d'émettre en
fait des suggestions pour essayer de
faire avancer les choses d'un côté ou
d'un autre
attention madame malheureusement pas le
volant voir l'émission parce que si vous
n'avez producteur de l'émission
des piscines c'est le débat mais faut
pas débattre dans ces l'assassin domaine
des berniques sait ce qu'il faut faire
c'est parce que depuis tout à l'heure la
lasser ses parts impôts c'est à dire
soit c'est la police tout le temps qui
est en cause soit c'est tout le temps la
banlieue au bout d'un moment faut qu'on
essaye de tous les deux parties trouver
une solution et essayer de se mettre
d'accord sur qu'est-ce qui pourrait être
bien pour l'un ou pour l'autre et je
pense que personne autour de cette table
a accusé l'entièreté des forces de
police sauf le maillot gym 6,6 des
coupables mais quand je vous écoute
rassure le montrer du doigt ici c'est
l'état la défaillance de l'état le
désengagement de l'état envers ces
policiers et le manque de moyens et le
manque de ressources que vous avez etc
mais je pense malheureusement que vous
vous êtes un peu trompé de posture et je
connais ce que vous avez écrit guillaume
j'ai lu vos interviews donc je sais que
s'il ya des bons et des mauvais je sais
vous faites partie des bons mais là
quand vous prenez partie contre t hawk
qui raconte son histoire ou contre amal
qui vient raconter l'histoire de sa
famille moi je crois partie contre la
famille attention c'est pas bien j'ai
dix ans et je pèse bien sûr sa fondation
il est question d'une question de
posture ne plaît pas vous ne pouvez pas
être dans la posture ne suis pas dans
une posture où j'avais vécu cette
famille avec son statut de patron sur
votre temps là on voudrait sur le coup
plus globale on pas pour parler des
problèmes que vous connaissez mais pas à
les contrer ces gens ça changeait pas
contre elle à 100 chaque fois je veux
juste dire qu'en fait à chaque fois
qu'il ya une usage d'armes à feu par la
police selon cette dame
la police est coupable avant même qu'ils
enquêtent elle n'a pas dit ça si alors
salut la ctcc elle laisse deviner la
direction du tout en quoi la junte
birmane a condamn jugé et que le monde à
bernard laporte
à ma demande serge berna bernard lacombe
a évoqué tous les mois je connais pas la
balle yeux donc je vais pas dire il vous
allez l'écouter et je connais pas
j'entends dire j'ai des potes qui sont
je le disais tout à l'heure fonctions de
police dont il me parle
olivier marchal le premier le seul
réalisateur qui ont embrasé les acteurs
il a évoqué des scènes il m'a dit
bernard j'ai arrêté parce que j'allais
faire une bêtise simplement donc j'ai
parlé avec les gens mais moi ce qui me
gêne c'est que karim a évoqué thaler
c'est quand vous êtes en train de vous
opposer mais vous êtes ensemble
je voudrais qu après ce débat des gens
me disent mais vous êtes d'accord on à
dire vous vous ouvrez si vous recevrez
pour que tout se passait bien
malheureusement effectivement il avait
drame et c'est terrible drame est arrivé
à votre frère
c'est terrible mais moi qui suis un
petit peu de sérieux qui vous regardent
unis mais on ne résoudra jamais le
problème on n'y arrivera jamais jeu sur
les sols est toujours sûr c'est sûr
c'est sûr chacun cherchait réserve c'est
ta faute c'est ma faute et c'est on n'y
arrivera jamais la phrase des ministres
excusez moi petit coq de la phrase les
ministres colonne qui s'en va je me suis
effondré je me suis fou rire je viens
qu'est ce qu'on fait alors nous
qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors à mal vous
dire a ajouté le clou alors moi je
voulais rajouter que ce qui me dérange
bien évidemment que tous les policiers
ne sont pas à mettre dans le même sac
j'en connais certains qui nous ont
soutenus mais en off
voyez-vous os que normal voilà en off et
qu'est ce qu'ils me disent ils me disent
écoute à mal va jusqu'au bout parce que
nous on peut plus vivre ça nous on a
envie de dire les choses mais si on les
dit haut et fort on est mis au placard
donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait de ces bons
policiers qui serait amené à faire un
travail correctement ça veut dire quoi
on le sur le dit haut et fort qu il y
dit quoi ça veut dire qu'on les met au
placard et victoire sur lyon efforts
pour les hauts faits de la réalité on
connaît ce qui est des bavures que les
délinquants
je voulais je vous ai pas entendu
pas son genre avait entendu le
déroulement ericsson et rim d'accord